good evening London welcome to Piers
Morgan on sense that Hollywood loves
nothing more than telling the rest of us
how we should live and how we should
think it's heavy on the preach light on
the practice this week stars and
supermodels flew in on private jets
taking a very well-earned break from
hatrings about their carbon footprint
attention for detail for the Met Gala in
New York and what is now routinely a
nauseating annual romp of tone death
extravagance became a glistening
exhibition of Holly woke hypocrisy well
the whole event was built as a tribute
to the late Fashion King Carl Lagerfeld
indisputably one of the all-time great
designers a visitor from outer space
would be forgiven for thinking he was
some kind of hybrid non-binary Fusion of
Mother Teresa and Nelson Mandela by the
time this lot had finished the other
night but let's compare and contrast
some of lagerfeld's opinions with those
peddled by the Stars oozing their
tributes to him on the red carpet here's
Margot Robbie
yeah this dress was owned by Cindy
Crawford in 1993. they remade it for me
and it's uh obviously a call design and
I feel really great in it actually it's
incredible obviously the Met's always an
exciting night but I had the great
privilege of Getting to Know Carl to an
extent I was the last Chanel Ambassador
that he picked what an honor yeah it is
an honor now nobody bows uh in
admiration more to Margaret Robert than
me one of the great actresses in the
world right now and a lovely lady met
her a couple of times but that's the
same Margot Robbie who's a vocal
advocate for gay marriage
famously wearing a pro-gay marriage
t-shirt for an appearance on Saturday
Night Live I've got no issue with that
obviously
but Lagerfeld did I'm against gay
marriage he told Vice magazine the same
year before launching a stunning
broadside against gay parents adopting
children
surely some mistake Margot
and then it was Jared Leto dressed up as
a cat in homage apparently to Carl
lagerfeld's beloved pet
and yet here is missiletto in 2015
giving an impassioned speech about
refugees of the Syrian crisis
by the way many of us here
are the sons and the daughters of
immigrants
[Applause]
and Steve Jobs
the Sun
of a Syrian immigrant
very moving very laudable but what about
his hero carlographer well in a shocking
interview on the same Refugee crisis he
evoked the Holocaust to attack former
German Chancellor Angela Merkel for
taking in too many refugees from Syria
or the enemy of the Jewish people is he
effectively called them the list of the
double standard goes on Kim Kardashian
joined the sycophantic parade of course
she did she turned up the opening of a
paper envelope but despite Lagerfeld
saying she was to blame for a robbery
that she suffered in Paris because she
flaunts her wealth on Instagram he
literally victim blamed her but she
forgave him because she gets a chance to
wear a nice dress in a tribute to Carl
Lagerfeld it'll be the center of media
attention which is really what she loves
doing most never mind the hypocrisy and
then there's that my old friend Emily
balachowski a vocal body positivity
Advocate lioness of the metoo movement
appeared to have forgotten that lagerfel
must describe curvy women as fat mummies
and said models should expect to be
groat
this is the same ridiculous hypocrisy
that leads to fugitive pedophile Roman
Polanski bagging an Oscar understanding
Innovation after his conviction an
ovation led by Meryl Streep while the
rest of us are just invited to forget
about it
now I've had many run-ins with the
British actress and activist Jamila
Jamil she can be incredibly irritating
and she would say exactly the same thing
about me but today she wrote this in
response to the Met Gala this isn't
about cancer culture it's not even about
Carl it's about showing how selective
Council culture is within liberal
politics in the most blatant way so far
it's about showing why people don't
trust liberals because a slippery double
standards like this
well for possibly the first time ever
maybe the only time
I agree with her she's right if you're
going to use your positions of privilege
to preach woke morality for the minions
back home you should start by practicing
yourselves and maybe avoid treating as
your hero somebody whose opinions are
the complete opposite to Everything You
Preach